CHRIS YERGA: Good
morning, San Francisco.
Hello.
We applauded them out, man.
Thanks so much, ladies
and gentleman here
in the audience, and
everyone on YouTube globally,
for joining us here today.
I am Chris Yerga.
And it's my pleasure to do
the kick-off here today.
So let's talk about
kick-offs, though, right?
Generally speaking,
kick-offs don't really
have a whole lot of content.
It's more about
introducing the players
and flipping coins
and maybe every once
in awhile, a jet flies over
or something like that.
But there isn't really a whole
lot of football going on.
And today is kind of similar.
So what I want you guys to do is
think about the next 10 minutes
you're going to have with me as
an amuse-bouche for your mind
to try to get yourself
ready for the jam
packed day that we
have coming up for you,
because it is crazy.
We have 14 separate talks
coming up after this one
covering all aspects
of Android gaming
with some awesome
speakers across Google.
And I am giving you
my personal guarantee.
There is not a drum
solo in the bunch.
We are playing all
the hits today.
So use those bathroom
breaks carefully.
Now, what I am going
to use my time to do
is talk to you a little
bit about some context here
for the history of
multiplayer gaming.
And I think there's
really no better place
to start than the 12th century.
Now, when we think about
the 12th century, some of us
think about secret
societies and Freemasons
and all that kind of stuff.
But then, just as now,
they loved to game.
Certainly, twitch games
were very popular there.
And they played it hardcore.
No respawns at all.
But what I would really
want to talk to you
about right now
is a particularly
famous and important
turn-based multiplayer match
that happened between
two monarchs at the time.
So we have here on the left
Henry I of Britain versus Louis
VI-- that's 10 King
Louis before the ones
that I know anything
about-- of France.
And this isn't a
metaphor or anything.
These guys actually did play
a turn-based multiplayer game
across a very long distance.
So we want to talk a little bit
about what kind of architecture
they used.
So clearly, in
order to play a game
over that kind of
distance, you need
some sort of network transport.
And I know these
guys are loaded.
So they had the best
technology of the day.
It was a little
bit high latency.
And from time to time,
it could be lossy.
But no problem-- they
had a network transport.
And you can deal with those
things at the protocol level,
and so they had a
protocol as well.
Now, we can kind of think of
it as the moral equivalent
of a wire protocol.
And what it was, was
essentially messages
that they would deliver
to each other on ships
with coded instructions on
how to mutate the game states
and keep a game session going.
Now, of course, this immediately
introduces a third problem
that they had to solve,
which is somehow,
you need to keep a
view of the game state
both in England and France
and keep it synchronized.
And so they had a
solution to that, too,
which was to keep chess
boards at each side.
And then you take
the pieces and then
send a responding move
when the time came.
So obviously, what
we're talking about here
is correspondence chess.
And even though it happened
nearly 1,000 years ago,
the way they solved
this problem,
in sort of broad strokes,
looked very much like the way
that we build systems today
to solve the same problems.
But the thing that I find
far more interesting about it
is that the game itself and
the players who played it also
responded to ecosystem
dynamics in a way that's
very similar to how
people respond today.
So for example, there
was a huge increase
in correspondence
chess after 1840,
when flat rate data
plans arrived in Europe.
So you might ask yourself what
does a flat rate data plan
look like in the 1800s?
And it looks like this thing.
So this is called the
penny black stamp.
It's the first stamp that
allowed flat rate postage
delivery to a fairly ubiquitous
service area in a way
that we think of stamps today.
And it fundamentally
revolutionized
sending messages at a distance.
And so prior to this,
it was complicated.
The receiver would
pay, and it was
based on how far things
traveled and stuff like that.
So when the market provided a
more economical way to do this,
the gamers rushed in
and filled the vacuum.
Similarly, the
game itself adapted
to technology
drivers of the time.
So when the telegraph
came around,
games of correspondence
chess immediately
started using this more low
latency transport mechanism.
And similarly, when
radio came along,
that shared the
latency characteristics
but also meant that
no wires were needed.
Soon after, games of chess
where one or more of the parties
were on ships started being
recorded in the literature.
And the final thing,
also, is that people
love to tweak stuff, right?
So there was a lot of
protocol optimization
that happened as well,
from the 1600s, where
you have a whole sentence
to describe a chess move,
down to a few hundred years ago,
it got actually pretty compact,
and there was actually
even variants of this
for being transmitted
over telegraph or radio
or other sorts of transport.
So the thing that I want
you to take away from this
is one really
important fact, which
is that the desire to
game is ubiquitous.
The only thing that really
changes the size of the market
is how available
it is to people.
So 1,000 years ago,
you needed to be
a monarch with a flotilla of
boats to play a game of chess
with someone at a distance.
But as the bar to that
reduces and reduces,
the gamers always rush
in, just like water
finding the lowest
spot in a room.
It's almost like
physics or math.
The desire to game is
completely ubiquitous.
And these same dynamics
have played out
across our own lifetimes.
Actually-- OK.
Well, this was during
my lifetime, at least.
I'm not sure if everyone here
has the same shared experience.
But in the '80s, there was this
great age of arcade cabinets
and arcades as a location-based
entertainment solution.
So people could have
these awesome immersive,
for the time,
gaming experiences.
The problem was there's only
one cabinet for lots of people,
and you had to drive down there.
But it was a big step up.
And then of course, when
the home console and PC
era came on, it turned that
whole thing on its head.
So now, you're only
sharing the game
console between a couple
people in the family.
And it's right
there in your house
where you could use
it not all the time,
but certainly every day.
And of course, that all
has changed to the point
now, where in many
regions of the world,
for all practical purposes, it's
one to one devices to gamers.
Everybody has it with
them all the time.
And so it's then expanded
the market exponentially.
And I think we should
really take a moment
to think about how unique
this point of time is
and how rich this
opportunity is for us.
And what it's really done is
it's created this world where
everyone is a gamer, no
matter where you live.
So if you're riding
the subway in Korea,
chances are you're playing
a game on your mobile phone.
But if not, you
might be looking up
at the ads for mobile
games on the monitors that
are in the subway.
Or if you're in Seattle, you
might see a giant Angry Bird
hanging from the Space Needle.
And this is a particularly
salient example for me,
because a few years ago, when
my daughter was maybe five
and my mom was in her 80s,
they had a conversation
about Angry Birds.
They were both completely
aware of Angry Birds.
They played the game.
And I think it really speaks
to the ubiquity of gaming
and how it's really
touching everyone
but is also showing
up everywhere.
In Japan, we actually
have vending machines
where you can go get games
for your Android device.
There's a sushi
restaurant I eat at.
And if you look at
the top row there,
you'll see that every
single seat has a monitor.
That's because while you're
sitting there for 30 minutes,
it would be a shame if
you didn't get a chance
to play a game on the
monitor against the computer.
So every once in
a while, it beeps,
and you play some
Rochambeau or whatever.
Gaming is everywhere.
It's completely
pervasive in our culture.
And so what that
has created is a ton
of momentum for
the market, which
creates a ton of opportunity
for all of us here today.
So think about it.
We have over a billion
activated Android devices,
and three in four Android
users are playing games
on those devices.
These are huge numbers.
And we also have had huge
momentum for Google Play Games
Services.
We launched it just
around six months ago,
and we have 75 million users
actively using Play Games
Services now and incredible
momentum going forward.
So with that backdrop, I
want to take you real quickly
through some of the stuff you're
going to be hearing today.
This is a pictorial
version of it.
Basically, we think of it
in a couple steps here.
You've got to build
your app, right?
You're going to
build with Play Games
Services and Google's cloud.
You then want to connect
up to players and to people
who want to
experience your game.
So you can connect up with
millions of users in the Play
store or create
online communities
on YouTube or with
Google Play Games app.
Also, you want to experiment.
And so we got some great talks
from Google Analytics talking
about some of the ways that you
can get data and let data drive
your decisions about
how to make your gaming
experiences great,
which also helps you
with monetization, which
is our next topic here.
Clearly, we're all
in it for the art,
but it's kind of
nice if you don't
have to have a day
job in addition to it.
So we provide an ever
expanding set of ways
to monetize your apps, obviously
through ad supported models
via AdMob and in
ever increasing ways
to allow users to pay in
the Google Play Store.
And of course, we'll
be talking a little bit
about stuff that
allows you to explore
some new frontiers
and new platforms,
like the one you see in front of
you, and maybe some fun stuff,
some blobby Jell-O that
sort of bounces around
and some other new
capabilities that we're
going to unleash on you guys.
So with that context of
this massive opportunity
and a lot of really
sharp tools we're
going to give you to help
capitalize on that opportunity,
I thank you for your time today.
And it's my pleasure
to hand it over
to-- you're familiar
with this term of,
oh, that's a tough
act to follow.
These guys are a
tough act to precede.
When we rehearsed
yesterday, I realized
I had to up my
game a little bit.
So I'm going to hand
over to the dynamic duo.
Thank you so much for
your time this morning,
and enjoy the day.